[Music]
if I could describe how I felt before
going to therapy in one word lost yeah
conflicted sad I mean I was just really
sad
chaotic no it was in October my
sophomore year of college
I was at my then girlfriend's house and
all of a sudden my brain started having
this downward spiral at my chest erasing
I was having trouble breathing then the
panic attacks kept happening when I
started going through depression and I
wasn't my full self I didn't feel like
there was anyone I could talk to you
about it because I felt like my friends
only wanted to be around me when I was
like my 100% goofy like super happy self
so I started thinking about going to
therapy I tried to talk myself out of it
like a billion times therapy is for
people who have like big traumatic
problems not like a 19 year old who's
depressed and like can't study
I kept discounting my own feelings and
so thank God I got to go in there and
talk about these fears with her she was
like - how are you feeling and then
suddenly it was just like every thought
I ever had poured out when you go
through depression or anxiety you often
think like something had to have
happened there had to have been an event
and like oh now you're sad like but
that's not the case sometimes you're
just sad my reason for wanting to do
therapy was partly related to just like
goals and things that I want to get done
and feeling that there may have been a
little bit of a stagnancy and it's been
life changing one of my larger
motivators for being open about going to
therapy is the fact that I am a black
man and I don't think that within the
community of black men the topic of
therapy has talked about very often
giving other black men encouragement
that you know it is okay and we can do
this - that also helps us overcome a
stigma that we can't we're not you know
we're not allowed to take care of our
mental health there's a privilege for a
lot of people there's a privilege of
having insurance
not having to pay $150 for every session
yeah the system isn't really set up for
everybody to have access to that that's
not okay so I started going to therapy a
relatively young age I was around 17
years old I was actually diagnosed with
anorexia around the same time that I was
diagnosed with anorexia
I was also diagnosed with depression my
being gay played a big part in my eating
disorder it's really easy to feel shitty
about your body as like a guy in an
LGBTQ community as a recently identified
queer person with an eating disorder
going to therapy was super helpful it
was really essential and I don't know
what I would have done without that I
know people can think that going to
therapy means that you're mentally
unstable I would sort of try to erase
those Klum's if you can it is literally
just like talking to a friend whose job
is to just listen to you and talk to you
and provide objective advice my senior
year I was taking 21 and 24 credit hours
and I had two very close friends get
killed so I went to therapy and I
started to talk to them it was a very
cathartic feeling because it allowed me
to grieve it was very important for me
to have another black woman therapist it
feels good to be able to speak to a
therapist and relay certain things and
they don't think that you're making it
up it's good to just be like you've been
through this too I'm sure so having an
older black woman be able to talk to me
but also walk me through my healing was
a very beautiful thing learning to go
through the fields so often we're sort
of taught to suppress them and keep it
moving and act like we're okay if you're
not okay and that's
I was grieving from having lost my
father a month after that I lost my
grandfather and moved away from my
family I'd left my job that I loved and
I didn't have a job it was just hard to
even get out of the house I was finally
like okay I need to do something for
myself and get off my ass and like do
something it was very helpful for me
because I felt like I had this person
that I was accountable to I don't know
everything kind of just changed after
that obviously therapy deals with people
all over the spectrum of mental health
you know you don't have to suffer from
anxiety or depression to go to therapy
even if you don't think you benefit even
if you don't think you qualify even if
you think you're like super happy and
like uber blessed I think everyone would
benefit from therapy capable I feel
really capable should know I feel
empowered
better and stronger liberating I felt
like validation I think it's the best
thing you can do for yourself
[Music]